thank you for the invitation to talk
today so what I'm really going to do is
because I'm the first climate modeler to
speak then I'm going to give quite an
introductory talk and and actually talk
a bit about give an introduction to
climate models so how do they work
what's the physical basis behind climate
models and I'll actually give a bit of a
historical perspective as well because I
think that's interesting to sort of put
current models into some context is to
know sort of how they've improved or
changed in the past and then you know
therefore you can perhaps have some
understanding perhaps how they might
improve in the future as well so then
I'll talk about the evaluation of
climate models so how good are they
what are their strengths and weaknesses
and then I'll move on to climate
sensitivity talk about well people
already covered this already so you're
talking about the definitions but in
particular what I'm gonna focus on is
thinking about the time scales involved
and in particular very long time scales
and do we need to take those into
account at what point in the future do
we need to take those into account and
what are these very long term feedbacks
that are may play some role in
determining climate sensitivity and then
I'll talk at the very end about about
transient change and what I think is the
importance of it's a point that Kevin
made earlier the importance of
considering not just climate sensitivity
but also regional Geographic change in
temperature and also other variables and
extreme events etcetera etc so just to
kick things off an interest and
introduction to climb models now actions
in sort of conceptual terms climate
models are really quite quite simple in
some ways and in the core of every
general circulation model or GCM is
actually a set of primitive equations
that you can actually write down on on
one page and actually solving them is
much more is much more complex obviously
they incorporate sort of the fluid
dynamic the fundamental fluid dynamics
Newton's equations of motion the first
law of thermodynamics conservation of
mass and moisture the ideal gas so these
are all things that we've known for for
centuries actually the underlying
physics that is in a climate model
actually solving the set of equations on
a rotating sphere is actually is more
complex and where you have to take into
account things like what's going on at
the pole
and things like that it gets it makes it
more complex but really the fundamental
science of this part this core of
climate models is actually very well
known the way that we tend to or most
models are formulated to set up and
solve this set of equations is
Illustrated sort of conceptually here we
tend to divide the world up into a
series of grid boxes or sort of matrix a
three-dimensional matrix of boxes that
go up in the atmosphere and down in the
ocean and actually what the way the
models work you formulate this set of
equations in this matrix of grid boxes
and the models can't what it means the
models can't tell you anything a spatial
scale that's smaller than one of these
grid boxes so you know if you're in this
example this is quite an old slide now
so this resolution is relatively low but
it's very yeah UK centric slide but you
know it can tell you something about
sort of averages on the scale of the UK
but if you wanted to know the climate in
the future in New Haven for example it
would do because that's much smaller
than the spatial scale of when these
boxes you a typical client model can
just not give you that level of
information so you have this so you have
this call this fluid dynamical component
if you like but then there's a lot of
other processes that going on we also
take after take into account now for
example the absorption of scattering of
radiation in the atmosphere and in
particular sub-grid scale process so
these are any physical process that is
occurring on a spacial scale that's
smaller than one of these grid boxes
actually we can't simulate that using
fundamental equations we have to do some
approximation for that process that and
that approximations they can come from
observation so we observe the
large-scale properties of convection and
clouds etc and represent that in our in
our climate law we can use the same
fundamental equations that we think work
on a very small parcel of air apply
those to a you know scale that up to a
larger scale and perhaps end up with
some what we call tunable parameters in
our model that represent these these we
don't know what the number is of these
of this particular tunable parameters
but they're sort of a scaling factor if
you like for some of these processes and
so there are there there are these
parameter so-called parameterize ations
of these subsequent practice sub-grid
scale processes that
exist in both the atmosphere and the
ocean in in climate models so this is
sort of the framework that we have in
particular one of the largest
uncertainties associated with the clouds
the fact that the typical grid box size
of a climate model is actually much
larger than the spatial scale on which
clouds are forming and developing means
that actually this is one of the most
uncertain parts of climate models and
means that it's actually a result of
that why a model that's developed in the
u.s. compared to the UK compared to
different institutions across the world
end up giving different results tend to
be not because of differences in this
part in the fundamental physics but in
the way these sub grid scale processes
are represented so that's a sort of
introduction to climb model I thought
give a brief potted history of actually
how they developed the first ever
climate model developed this by this guy
LF Richardson who formulated his grid
boxes actually just over Northwest
Europe and he carried out the first ever
numerical weather forecast in 1970 now
this was actually before the advent of
computers so he did this by hand by
writing out the equations solving them
by hand with using a slide rule etcetera
etcetera and he actually um what he
found was he wrote down the fundamental
crazy and solved them actually
unfortunate what he found is that all
the maths in his model saw piled up in
one or two grid boxes and all the mass
and other grid boxes in other regions
that you know you ended up with almost
no atmosphere in some of these boxes
turned out he hadn't it wasn't because
he made a mistake in his calculations
but actually he hadn't properly
accounted for the boundaries in the
model and also some of these sub grid
scale processes basically hadn't put
enough diffusion in his model to sort of
account for some of the that would have
counteracted some of these problems he
had anyway that was the first sort of
numerical weather forecast that we had
in 1917 the first one actually carried
on a computer was by Joule Charney and
this was using this is a picture of his
computer that any AK that in 1950
actually solved a very similar set of
equations to those that LF Richardson
used and we needed the first realistic
24-hour weather forecasts on this on
this machine unfortunately for him
actually
it took 24 hours to run so in terms of
weather forecasting wasn't particularly
useful but it was you know it was you
know is that's how science progresses so
nowadays supercomputers actually look
very similar to how they were in those
days but I've see their because of
miniaturization everything's you know
much more powerful it's it so just going
back to if you ought that your typical
iPhone or you know the chip and the
mobile phone your pocket is about almost
a hundred thousand times more powerful
than this machine here and this is
actually a few hundred thousand times
more powerful than your iPhone so that's
the sort of progression that we've had
and now so that's the progression in
terms of the computation actually them
what goes into the models also improved
and increase so in terms of the mid 70s
you had a model that may be
representative process had they they've
always had this dynamical quorum but in
terms the physics and sub-grid scale
processes represented in the model in
the 70s it a very simple representation
may be including clouds and
precipitation in the 70s and 80s as we
move forward in time you get more and
more processes actually including the
models misses an image from the last
IPCC report showing sort of the size of
these funny cylinders I think it's
supposed to represent the complexity of
the different processes that have gone
in the models from the 70s up to ar5 the
most recent IPCC assessment report here
and this you know one of the comments
previously was that why is that range of
climate sensitivity actually stayed the
same why isn't that as we go forward in
time when our uncertainties in climate
sensitivity shrinking and actually this
is one of the reasons is because over
time we're including more and more
processes and so because of that the
your uncertainty is basically growing
with time although your understanding of
some of the more fundamental physics and
pro-civil if you had them if we had a
model now that had the same number of
processes that the early models of
Charney had for example then i think
there would be much more convergence
than what he had but now we improve we
include a lot more a lot more processes
so as well as the amount of
physics and chemistry and biology that's
being included also the spatial scale of
these grid boxes is also increasing with
time so in the 90s you had a this is
actually you might not let us recognize
it this is actually you're up here but
as we go down in for the current
generation of models you get a flavor
for the resolution this is just a region
within a whole global model and then
looking to the to the future the IPCC
anticipates that by the next IPCC
assessment report we might be looking at
a resolution of perhaps tens of
kilometers each one of these boxes so a
lot along with this along with this
increasing complexity and resolution
actually the amount the vault just the
volume of code increase this was a
figure that I found quite interesting
it's actually the number of lines of
code in a typical climate model and
actually we're up a typical model now
this is the UK Hadley Center model is
about a million lines of code so clearly
there is no one any sort of climate
institution actually understands every
aspect of of their climate model these
are models that are developed by you
know different groups concentrating on
different parts of the model and
developing something that's actually
used to put that number in context
million lines of code I did a bit of
googling and found it actually a typical
computer game is actually also about a
million lines of code so so moving on so
yeah so thinking about how good how good
are these client models you know what
how good are they representing different
processes and different variables and
and so just so this is from the last
IPCC report this is quite an old
generation model now the UK one have cm3
and this shows the distribution of model
predicted temperature for the current
climate effectively in degree C and here
you have a map of observation so what we
think the real answer is now there's
some one there's uncertainty associate
with the observations in particular in
regions like Antarctica where we have
very few observations so this is just
this is hiding a bit of uncertainty
actually in the observations themselves
if you look at this it look at the first
glance it looks pretty it looks pretty
good but actually it's quite misleading
because you could almost get you could
get something that very like this just
by saying the poles are warmer that
holes are cooler than equatorial regions
and we put in some sort of cooling as we
go to higher regions and what so what
we're really interested in is sort of
the anomaly and again this is the
previous IPCC report showing the error
if you like in cutting all the client
models that took part in that last IPCC
report where it's bright red the models
are too warm by about five degrees C C
and where they're blue that's who cool
by about five degrees C and and you know
you see that these models are very
different they have errors in different
different regions that are summery some
areas that appear particularly
problematic that are perhaps a cold bias
in a lot of the models in in northern
Eurasia and also nothing to point out
it's that there's you know there isn't a
single model out there that doesn't have
an error somewhere of at least five
degrees C in one somewhere another sort
of point of interest this is the
previous generation like I said of the
UK model it actually ended up in the
last IPCC report being one of the the
better models and the Met Office
invested a huge amount money in
improving a lot of the the physics and
the resolution in the model but actually
because when the model is first
developed you need to like I said it's
got a lot of these internal parameterize
ations and actually knowing what value
they should have is actually quite
uncertain and so that the process of
trying to get your model the best fit as
possible for the observations a tuning
process is undertaken as a new models
being developed that's actually quite
difficult the models very slow to run
and so for example then more recent
models don't always do better this is a
more recent model and this one don't
that you don't always get an improvement
in the actual climatology although
actually some of the underlying physics
and thermodynamics might be being better
represented and this shows a figure of
the error actually in the average in the
average model so if you mean all the
climate models together and compare that
with observations and actually this does
better than any one single model so the
average the average model is better than
any one individual model as well as took
just to highlight a point and make a bit
later as well as looking at temperature
we are the IPCC and the C MIT which is a
couple model into comparison project
puts a huge amount of effort into
evaluating these models
just compared to temperature of it
compared to a huge range of observations
for example precipitation sea ice and
this is a this is a very colorful figure
from current IPCC report where so you've
got all the different models along here
and you've got a number of different
variables a number of different
observational data sets that have been
used to evaluate these climate models on
this actus doesn't really matter what
they are for the point I'm making but
what the colors show is where it's where
you have a blue color it's that
particular model is better compared to
observations than a sort of the median
climate model where it's red it's
actually worse than the median flow
model and so you can see there are some
models for example I'll pick on the CFM
as Kevin theory with that here so
actually this is one of the one of the
best models and that it performs better
than the median model it's blue for a
lot of these variables but actually the
multi model mean which is the one on the
far left the average of them all all the
models is actually for the majority of
variables is actually better than any
single individual models so actually
there's sort of a wisdom of crowds
effect going on if you like in that the
average model is better than any
individual one so as well as well as
evaluating the model compared with a
snapshot of current climate we can also
look at time series and obviously this
is very important where if we're
interested in the transient evolution of
climate going into the future and and
here we've got a spaghetti plot of
temperature anomalies so zero is sort of
an average of the late 1800s or
something and we've got 1.5 degrees
above that in the global map in the
global average mean up here along here
we go from the 1890s up to the present
day and the black solid line you can
almost see in here is our observation so
some so an observational representation
from observations of currently evolution
over the last hundred years and the
individual lines are basically every
model that took part every GCM that took
part in the IPCC report and you can see
that it captures the models capture a
lot of the variability actually so some
of this is associated with volcanic
events
gone off which of these marks here where
we get quite a rapid but relatively
short leaf cooling but the gradual
increase in the warming of the last in
particular of the last 150 years but in
particular of the last 50 60 years or so
is actually very well represented
perhaps less well represented very n but
I think that's something that comings
gonna talk about a bit later but
basically we have from this we can gain
some sort of it's a good way of
evaluating the moles we can go back over
longer time scales so now we're looking
at so this is where the observations
become much more uncertain but now we're
looking at a thousand years of
temperature evolution now these are the
data now is in the these Grey's of
shaded area and the model so that the
colored lines but again even on this
time scale of a thousand years so that
by observations what I'm talking about
now is data of a lot of data from
tree-ring analysis for example so some
sort of proxy if you like estimate
temperature but again some of the
features of the long-term cooling at the
last of the early part of the earlier
part of the millennia and then the
warming in the last 100 years so it's
very well captured by the models the
relative magnitude of that compares the
observations we can also go even further
back in time this is something a couple
of people have mentioned about going
back into deeper time and telling us
something about bigger magnitude changes
and here we've got on the right we've
got land surface temperature change and
on the Left we've got sea surface
temperature change for a future
projection projection prediction at the
top for end of the century and down here
we've got three different past time
periods so here we've got the last ice
age in the background is a model
prediction or an average lots of
different models and then the colored
dots represent again proxy observation
sort of indirect proxy observational
from the geological record of what the
temperature change right actually was
and so the last ice age here 21,000
years ago we've got the so called
Pliocene three million years ago and
down here we got the East I'm going
about 50 million years and what you can
see here is the temperature change from
the proxies is actually vastly outstrips
that predicted for a hundred years in
the future and that's because co2 levels
during this time were thought to be so
high but because of natural variations
and the timescale of those changes in
co2
actually much much slower than what
experiencing now but the key take-home
message here is actually in terms of the
magnitude of the observed in dots
compared to the model predicted in the
background is actually there's quite
good agreement there in terms of
actually the magnitude of temperature
change so that's a very good question so
in this case in terms of the last ice
well so in terms of this one ultimately
this is but this is actually ultimately
driven by changes in Earth's orbit in
fact so this is as the so called
eccentricity of the orbit how elliptical
it is and the actual tilt of the
rotation of the earth changes but but
that all that forcing that actually
leads to changes in carbon dioxide
concentration so and that in turn or
also associate with the orbital forcing
we have changes in ice sheet so actually
there's a there's the ultimate forcing
is all of it then we have a there's a
co2 component here and a fact that we've
got massive ice sheets over North
America yes so in this case those those
ice sheets here and not predicted by the
model so we don't have a co2 is
predicted it's sorry is prescribed here
but we know the number extremely well
from ice core records so going back here
20,000 years ago we know what that
number should be to within a few ppm
yeah so none of these models are
actually testing the carbon cycle
response of the model so none of them
are saying well if you had a you know
some external forcing how much would co2
change
all they're saying is that if you put a
co2 change into the model then does it
and keep that fixed and ignore any sort
of biochemical feedbacks then what's the
temperature response yes but in general
they you have to run that sort of model
for much much longer to get it into a
crib room and so typically that sort of
study is done by models of much lower
resolution and much low complexity but
they include a lot of biogeochemical
feedbacks as well and actually the co2
is prescribed in these is in these two
cases the main driver we think is
actually co2
and that is again a number that is put
into these put into the model not
predicted and Mark is Mark Ghani is one
of the world experts in actually trying
to reconstruct what the co2 level
actually was at this time that we then
put in the models so now I probably
better speed up a bit so climate
sensitivity we've had definitions about
this but what I'm really gonna think
about is what is do we mean by at
equilibrium so how do you actually
estimate climate sensitivity in a model
what you do is you have a sort of a
background climate simulation which is
bubbling along here and it's interesting
to know there is a lot of intra niall
variability it's not a smooth you know
in reality when we don't in the models
as well as the real world there's in
tranio variability there so you can have
a period of several years where actually
you might get cooling in climate
followed by warming so there's some sort
of stochastic stochastic variability in
there and then suddenly you increase co2
to calculate climate sensitivity
traditionally by a factor of two
actually this is a different experiment
we've multiplied it by four but anyway
and then temperature increases very
rapidly so rapidly that you can't even
see it at the beginning of this
simulation on this timescale of years
and then it gradually you would hope
would ultimately reach in at clipper and
this is an example where actually it's
very hard to see that this is you know
that this is when this what would be the
actually at quit the equilibrium the
true equilibrium climate response here
but because it's because these models
are so expensive to run to actually get
them to full equi Librium can actually
take you know actually literally months
and months if not years of model
simulation time so actually it's very
rarely done that we that we actually
reach an ultimate equilibrium so I'll
speed it I'll speed over this because
this is talking about how some of these
results the client sensitivity but again
to come at the thing of what do you
really mean about equilibrium what do we
need to include to get a true actually
but we actually need to include
everything in the earth system every
single process now there is no model out
there no model out there that actually
includes all these processes and
typically you know some of the important
ones that we think could play a really
important role on the time scale of
particular when we come to millennia is
actually ice sheets so there are
our models out there that's beginning to
include the fact that as climate warms
you get a change in the geometry of the
ice sheet they will start to melt get
changed in beedo reflectivity and
feedbacks associated with that but even
when they are included actually then
don't tend to be run out to equi Librium
long enough to actually realize what the
full true equilibrium climate
sensitivity is so ice sheet price is
very important associated with changes
associated with a reflectivity
associated ocean circulation if we dump
all this fresh water into the ocean also
vegetation change in vegetation and much
more beginning to be included in models
but again to actually run them out to
full equitable and the timescales
associated with vegetation are not very
well known but when you one thing you
can do is get a handle on some of these
processes by looking at the past and
looking at the observational record and
how ice sheets in vegetation have varied
in the past from you and include those
prescribed those changes in ice sheets
and vegetation in your model and if you
do that it turns out different people
have done this but it actually can do as
much as double your estimate of climate
sensitivity if you include some of these
long time scale process now what's
really disconcerting in some ways is
actually some of these process we
understand them so are on some of them
is so poor that actually we don't know
what the time scales are that are
associated with them so if you think
about the ice sheets for example we know
that that can cause a large amplifying
effect on climate sensitivity but there
are many processes for example as
actually start to melt they build up a
lot of water on the surface and this can
fall down so called mula crevasses in
the ice and this can lubricate the
bedrock of the ice and actually
accelerate the melting of an ice sheet
and actually the importance of that
process is something that we don't know
at the moment so when you ask us about
what are the timescales are what are the
likelihood of some of these effects and
amplifiers of climate sensitivity
actually we don't know the answer at the
moment because there's still a lot of
the physics of the system that we're
still trying to get to grips with in
there because they potentially occur on
a long time scale we don't have a good
observational record
she constrained them so I'll leave it at
apologies for overrunning be